25 enfants 10 femmes c'est le nouveau
contingent de djihadiste rapatrié en
France dans la nuit de lundi à mardi
dernier ces femmes et leurs enfants
étaient tous détenus dans le camp de
prisonniers djihadistes de roche située
dans le nord-est de la Syrie arrivé à
l'aube sur la base aérienne militaire de
Vélizy-Villacoublay dans les Yvelines
ils ont été prises en charge par les
autorités françaises sous une escort
ultra sécurisée une partie d'entre eux a
été conduite dans les locaux de la
sous-direction antiterroriste une autre
à la direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure les mineurs sont remis au
service chargé de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance et font l'objet d'un suivi
médico-social les adultes sont remises
aux autorités judiciaires compétentes
classées en garde à vue la plupart de
ces femmes adultes devaient ensuite être
présentés à un juge d'instruction puis
mise en examen pour association de
malfaiteurs terroristes ces françaises
étaient rendus volontairement dans les
territoires contrôlés par les groupes
djihadistes en zone Irak au syrienne
elles avaient été capturées au moment de
la chute de l'État islamique en 2019
depuis aux côtés de nombreuses femmes de
diverses nationalité c'est
ressortissantes françaises vivaient dans
les camps Dahl hall et de rôle contrôlés
par les Kurdes violence et dans des
mythes et les privations nombreuses il
reste dans ces camps une centaine
d'enfants de nationalités françaises qui
ne connaissent que la fange les barbelés
et la violence c'est la quatrième
opération collective du genre en un an
la dernière en date remonte au mois de
janvier dernier 15 femmes et 32 enfants
avaient été rapatriés jusqu'à l'été 2022
la France privilégiée les rapatriments
au compte-goutte de ses citoyens retenus
dans les camps par crainte notamment
d'éventuels actes terroristes sur son
sol ce qui lui a valu les critiques
répétées du Secrétaire général de l'ONU
Antonio guteres et de plusieurs ONG
humanitaires je peux dire call est le
pire camp qui existe au monde
aujourd'hui avec les pires conditions de
vie et d'énormes souffrances tous les
États membres doivent redoubler
d'efforts pour faciliter le rapatriement
sur Eding de leur ressortissants
condamné en septembre dernier par la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
pour le caractère arbitraire de sa
politique de rapatriement Harry a
infléchi sa doctrine mettant fin à la
politique du cas par cas plusieurs
observateurs mettent toutefois en garde
contre les conséquences de ce changement
de doctrine qui pourrait mettre en péril
la sécurité du territoire national
sont obligés de de suivre la politique
mais quand vous leur parlez en
tête-à-tête sur les problématiques
auxquelles ça va nous exposer à la fois
en termes de risques résiduel terroriste
mais aussi et surtout en termes
d'augmentation de de foyer de
prosélytisme islamiste dur l'analyse
entre le bénéfice et le risque est à mon
avis très largement déficitaire et
augmente objectivement le risque auquel
notre pays est confronté non seulement
risque terroriste mais surtout le risque
de la continuation de cette pénétration
de l'idéologie islamiste dont je
rappelle qu'elle veut quand même
détruire notre notre société et mettre
civilisation